well we've been on it rounded watch it
no around-the-clock is really in
particular that you'd like us to do to
hold thank no no he came offering
sympathy but for some it was just too
late the Prime Minister's deployment
here coincided with the military's
almost 200 soldiers are now on the
ground
there's at least 20 locations in South
Yorkshire alone that are on the Army's
to-do list do you think you personally
underestimated the impact of this when
you said that it was not on a national
level of an emergency no because
actually if you look at what's been
happening since the the flood began has
been has been round-the-clock
round-the-clock
monitoring of the situation the villages
from Fish Lake on the other side of the
river Don have been worst-hit among them
Dorothy whitehead tell me where your
where your home is it's over there all
the water and everything the Prime
Minister hadn't planned on visiting Fish
Lake but such was the feeling here
by mid-afternoon Dorothy was back on her
Road anyone who's been flooded will tell
you this is one of the hardest moments
is this all sinking in a bit now you
first look round no I'm dead inside
it's sim yeah no no I don't I don't know
I'm just going to look around and see if
there's any look a bit there can maybe
take me you'll get through it
yeah after the stress of this past week
the Prime Minister was also able to
offer this that nobody here will be left
out of pocket because of the floods the
500 pounds per household is just the
start and he can be in no doubt the
people of South Yorkshire will hold him
to that promise there may be fewer
flooded homes in Lincolnshire but the
impact here is vast the family the farms
this land are also angry I don't think
the Environment Agency are fit for
purpose if the rivers were maintained
better and dredged and the banks were
improved and upheld and maintained then
you know that yes I think they could
have been some flooding but nothing like
this scale
the Environment Agency are working 24
hours a day and are confident they've
done everything possible we don't
believe that any mistakes have been made
the whole system has been overwhelmed in
the last three or four days and so we
look to try Molly to where that's going
update the information and share that
with members of the public as quickly as
we can it's been the wettest autumn on
record that means it's unlikely to be
the last of the flooding this winter tom
Parmenter Sky News